les volontaires qui continue de creuser
des tranchées sur cette plage du centre
d'odessa où nous nous trouvons la
pression c'est particulièrement
accentuée hier soir lorsque les derniers
relevés satellites ont fait état de la
présence d'au moins quatorze navires de
la marine russe au large d'odessa parmi
lesquels elle des navires de
débarquement de troupes ces deux chars
un croiseur lance-missiles des navires
d'assaut amphibie un démineur les
services de renseignement ukrainiens que
nous avons contactés nous confirment
qu'ils craignent un assaut imminent
le maire de dessin craint une attaque
dans les deux ou trois jours quel serait
l'objectif de ces forces russes est-ce
qu'il s'agirait d'aller renforcer les
forces qui à l'heure actuelle piétine
dans la ville de nicolet leaf à 150
kilomètres d'ici ou alors est-ce que cet
assaut serait directement concentrer sur
cette ville d'odessa dans le doute on a
croisé ce matin en plusieurs dizaines
d'habitants qui préfèrent fuir la ville
au dessin qui pour l'instant été
épargnée par le fracas des bombes